A wise man once asked who watches the
Watchmen well the same goes for critics
from classic parodies to beloved sequels
here are movies that Rotten Tomatoes
critics were totally wrong about
Nicholas Cage loves to act it's as
simple as that he pours every ounce of
his soul into his roles no matter what
caliber of script is tossed onto his
desk whether it be an oscar-winning
performance in the existential
Heartbreaker Leaving Las Vegas or a zany
turn as a literary agent who believes
he's becoming a vampire in the black
comedy Vampire's Kiss
and don't forget big budget Blockbusters
with over-the-top plots like 2004's
National Treasure he definitely goes all
in on these Adventures too and that's
the main reason this one is worth your
time the film follows Ben a noted
historian and treasure hunter who sets
out to discover a hidden secret at the
heart of the United States it also
involves a healthy dose of conspiracy as
both the Templars and the Freemasons
have roles to play while a certain super
important American document is a central
part of the plot
we're gonna steal the Declaration of
Independence it's these sillier elements
that ensure National Treasure was never
going to be a critical darling as the
story is way too outlandish in fact most
reviews commented on the unbelievable
narrative as a major negative but it's
also the kind of wacky fun that makes
for great escapism in a similar way to
night of the museum or the mummy and
though the plot is unbelievable that
doesn't mean the script itself is bad in
fact structurally speaking it's very
well put together throw in a stellar
cast that includes Diane Kruger John
Voight Sean Bean and Harvey Keitel and
National Treasure is a great way to
spend a couple of hours especially if
you go into it not expecting to have to
think too hard about what's actually
going on
based on the Chris Van alsberg novel of
the same name Jumanji met with a mixed
reception when it hit Cinema screens in
1995. that might be surprising to some
people as the movie is often regarded as
the classic of the 1990s and the
franchises continued to grow with two
recent sequels starring the likes of
Dwayne Johnson and Jack Black the
original story finds Robin Williams
caught up in a mystical board game which
brings hazards from the jungle world
into real life
run
in many ways Jumanji is the ultimate
Comfort movie it's dated special effects
are more Charming than disruptive and
Robin Williams gives an on-brand
touching performance that makes us all
miss him just as much as some of his
higher rated films do God bless you in
fact everyone in Jumanji adds to the
magic of the film from Jonathan Hyde to
David Alan Greer and a young Kristen
Dunst throw in a great musical score and
a script with solid pacing and you've
got yourself one of those movies you can
turn on any time you feel the urge to
unplug from our current dystopia and
remember simpler times and better movies
sequels are a dangerous game especially
when the original is way better than it
has the right to be capturing that magic
twice is unlikely and this is certainly
the case with 2001's The Mummy Returns
or just because it pales in comparison
to the original doesn't mean it deserves
to be excluded from your DVD collection
hear us out sure it certainly has some
pretty clunky dialogue and isn't nearly
as memorable as the first installment
aside from one particularly Stellar
action sequence
oh I hate mummies a lot of people will
also remember the awful CGI for Dwayne
Johnson's Scorpion King character but
let's get real for a second sometimes
bad special effects age like fine wine
and make us laugh and reminisce rather
than scoff this is definitely the case
with the Rock's computer-generated
appearance and in the end it's
infinitely more enduring than similar
scenes of the same technical caliber
that pop up in other less than Stellar
sequels to beloved franchise favorites
and don't forget about the genuine
Chemistry Between Brendan Fraser's Rick
O'Connell and Rachel vice's Evelyn
Carnahan something that's sorely missing
from so many modern Blockbusters take
these sentiments into account and The
Mummy Returns is actually a hell of a
lot of fun
looking back on Jim Carrey's career now
it's fair to say that the cable guy
doesn't stand out as a strange entry in
his extensive filmography he's played a
wide variety of characters in a wide
variety of movies from absolute buffoons
like Lloyd and Dumb and Dumber To the
sensitive and flawed Joel in the
oscar-winning 2004 Masterpiece Eternal
Sunshine of the Spotless Mind why do I
fall in love with every woman I see who
shows me the least bit of attention
however context is important transport
yourself back to 1996 and imagine
experiencing Carrie's role as chip
Douglas and not having much to compare
to besides movies like Ace Ventura the
mask or the cringe-tastic Batman Forever
besides criticizing the heavy-handed
observations about gen X's obsession
with television this is what critics and
fans alike fixated on at the time of its
release people just weren't ready to see
Jim Carrey be anything other than a
lovable goofball granted he's still
plenty of a goofball in the film but the
silliness of his characters Often
overshadowed by the darkness that drives
his increasingly Disturbing Behavior and
ultimately it's this characterization of
the frightening yet bizarrely likable
chip that allows Carrie's talents to
shine through and create a truly
memorable performance that helps earn
the movie a place on this list on top of
that the film is filled with iconically
hilarious moments that would make
anybody laugh and plenty of well-placed
Pop Culture references including a Star
Trek inspired fight scene complete with
medieval armor the name is Spock if we
don't battle to the death
they will kill us both parodies are some
of the hardest types of Comedy to get
right and they often aren't appreciated
in their own time Spaceballs found that
out firsthand when it was released in
1987 meant to be a spoof of the original
Star Wars Trilogy and various other
Sci-Fi series The Mel Brooks movie
failed to impress critics it also failed
to inspire audiences at the box office
just about making back its budget with
takings of 38 million dollars however in
the intervening years Spaceballs has
become a cult classic and a comedy
favorite as well as being arguably Mel
Brooks's most popular release it
contains a wide array of excellent sight
gags including the sandy desert being
combed and quotes that will never expire
so we've never gone that fast before I
don't know if the ship can take us
[Music]
tickets in terms of casting the
Infectious Chemistry Between Bill
Pullman and John Candy gives the film a
heartwarming sense of camaraderie and of
course Rick Moranis puts in one of the
best performances of his career as the
comical Dark Helmet
the ring I can't believe you fell for
the oldest trick in the book
critics weren't all that fond of Taken
when it was first released back in 2008.
the Liam Neeson action film sees a
former Special Forces Soldier embark on
a mission to locate his missing daughter
and her friend after they're kidnapped
by traffickers while vacationing in
France I will look for you I will find
you
and I will kill you like many Thrillers
taken doesn't focus on the overarching
narrative as much as it does the action
the plot is simple and ultimately
unlikely some also criticize the acting
in the film but it's obvious that the
filmmakers weren't pining for an award
at the Cannes Film Festival it doesn't
pretend to be something it's not and
that's what so many critics and regular
moviegoers alike get wrong when they're
cooking up their hot takes we should be
thankful when action movies aren't
riddled with half-baked political
messages or pseudo-intellectual musings
that stifle the pacing sometimes it's
perfectly acceptable to just sit back
eat too much popcorn and let Liam Neeson
be a badass for an hour and a half
there are only a few films that
successfully blend the live action and
animation in a satisfying way most would
agree that Who Framed Roger Rabbit is
the prime example of a movie where they
actually managed to nail this difficult
blend Space Jam is undoubtedly another
instance even if it didn't resonate with
critics when it arrived in cinemas in
1996. the film features Michael Jordan
and the cast of The Looney Tunes in a
tale where they must defeat a team of
aliens who intend on enslaving them and
using them as attractions for their
amusement park more on mountain in a
game of basketball
the Dream Team well we're the mean team
wussy man
yeah it's a silly plot and the acting is
atrocious but that's not what matters
it's Jordan's genial nature and energy
that give the movie A lighthearted
authenticity that transcends space and
time seeing all of our favorite cartoon
characters come to life in the real
world alongside possibly the most
beloved sports star of all time will
always be enduring no matter what decade
we find ourselves in
equilibrium has one of the biggest gaps
in audience and critic scores on Rotten
Tomatoes with its poor review ratings in
direct opposition to the high marks
given by viewers many reviews were
scathing suggesting it was derivative
and void of any originality if you've
only seen trailers for the 2002 film no
one would blame you for agreeing with
them watching a black trench coat
wearing Christian Bale bust through
doors with a pistol in each hand and use
martial arts to dominate anyone who
stands in his way in a bleak dystopian
future it sure looks a lot like another
much more critically acclaimed movie
that came out a few years prior
I don't believe it
however if you watch the movie in its
entirety you'll realize how different it
actually is under the surface in a world
scarred by a nuclear World War III the
human population in Libya is kept under
control by a totalitarian government and
a drug that suppresses emotion Christian
Bale portrays Preston a cleric tasked
with executing those who dare to feel he
slowly begins to rebel against the
government as the film progresses and
his journey from Hardline enforcer to
revolutionary is a joy to see unfold
I'm coming
two years after the incredibly
successful Home Alone was released Home
Alone 2 lost in New York was an
inevitable sequel although its
predecessor was not a massive hit with
critics it made so much money at the box
office that was obvious a second film
would come the sequel fared even worse
with reviews disparaging the way it was
apparently completely derivative of the
original 1990 movie they're not wrong it
really does recycle pretty much every
component Kevin ends up on his own he
uses his resourcefulness to thwart Harry
and Marv he's reminded of the true
meaning of Christmas by being forced to
interact with a scary stranger who ends
up being one of the sweetest people ever
but consider this there's something to
be said about sequels that bring back
every actor from the original film in
fact the entire creative team including
director Chris Columbus and writer John
Hughes all returned for the movie this
makes it feel like a believable
heartfelt continuation not just a
brainless cash grab initiated by
indifferent producers and besides all
that who can deny the that it never gets
old watching Harry and Marv face off
against elaborate booby traps that are
quite a bit more catastrophic and
demented than those in the original
it might be hard to find people who are
willing to admit they don't like hook
that wasn't always the case what's now
considered a classic Adventure film for
the whole family was once lamb basted by
critics and seen as something of a
financial failure despite bringing in
more than 300 million dollars at the box
office even director Steven Spielberg
has expressed his disappointment with
the film
most of the criticism was concentrated
on the lack of original ideas to
differentiate this from a standard
retelling of the Peter Pan story others
were of the opinion that the plot was
weak arguing that the script drags a bit
in the middle even if you agree with
those criticisms there's still so much
to like about hook especially the acting
Robin Williams lends his enduring
passion to the character of Peter
cultivating a very human version of him
that elevates what could have easily
been a flaccid two-dimensional
performance in a lesser actor's hands
the same can be said for Dustin Hoffman
whose Captain Hook is simultaneously
likable and memorably villainous
and who didn't believe I could do it
who doubted me
Julia Roberts shines both literally and
figuratively as Tinkerbell
you are embarrassing me even Glenn Close
as an unlikely and uncredited Cameo as
the unfortunate pirate who ends up in
the dreaded boo box
[Applause]
beyond the performances the film looks
great on a technical level with
impressive sets and special effects
everything from Captain Hook's ship to
The Lost Boys colorful imaginary Feast
is a cinematic sight to behold John
Williams scores also often considered to
be some of his best work as well the
Mighty Ducks was never likely to be the
type of film that would go down well
with critics it's a feel-good story that
features every Trope you'd expect from a
sports film whether it's the underdog
team or the down on his luck reluctant
coach this 1992 comedy drama does little
on the way of innovating the genre so
what that's a weak reason to discard a
movie especially one that's meant
primarily for kids they aren't sitting
down with their families to search for
evidence that the filmmakers are being
derivative or lazy they are analyzing
character arcs or story beats they're
laughing at Goldberg when he farts in
the limo
They're laughing at the Players as they
struggle to pass eggs back and forth to
each other on the ice they're rooting
for Charlie as he takes the same game
deciding penalty shot that coach Gordon
Bombay missed when he was a kid they're
vicariously experiencing a meaningful
victory that comes as the result of good
sportsmanship and dedication these are
the types of movies kids should be
enjoying when there's still a ways off
from adulthood ultimately the critical
response to the Mighty Ducks is an
example of reviewers not considering the
intended audience the script is
competent the characters are memorable
and it's as rewatchable as any other
classic of the genre and it's obvious
that a whole bunch of people really
enjoyed it at the time and still do as
the franchise has since expanded into
multiple movies a television series on
Disney plus and even a real-life NHL
hockey team
comedy films often face a tough time
with critics and very rarely get
Universal Acclaim when they're released
even some of the best comedies don't
make an impression with reviewers
despite being hugely popular with
audiences Step Brothers is a great
example of this it missed out on a fresh
reading even though it's widely
considered to be one of the best comedy
movies of the last two decades the plot
revolves around two 40 year old men
Brennan and Dale who still live at home
and are forced to coexist with each
other after their respective single
parents get married increasing levels of
hilarity and debauchery ensue with Will
Ferrell and John C Reilly's characters
showcasing legendary acts of immaturity
as they try to drive each other out of
the house they eventually become
Inseparable but they're outlandishly
childish Natures remain for the majority
of the film it's hilarious touching and
endlessly quotable
if you were a chick who's the one guy
you would sleep with John Stamos what
did we just become best friends yep
famed film critic Roger Ebert was not
amused by the movie whatsoever giving it
one out of five stars and writing when
did comedies get so mean Step Brothers
has a premise that might have produced a
good time at the movies but when I left
I felt a little unclean of course this
is coming from a guy who thought that
the only funny part of Dumb and Dumber
was the blind kid being given a dead
parakeet
it's difficult to see what's not to like
about Reign of Fire it features a
post-apocalyptic modern world where
dragons have awoken from millions of
years of hibernation to wipe out almost
all of humanity with civilization
collapsed due in part to Humanity's poor
decision to use nuclear weapons to try
and eliminate the dragons hope is pinned
on the few survivors scattered across
the planet they plot to kill the dragon
leader and save themselves from certain
Extinction and if you don't think that
sounds rad you're lying to yourself the
movie Ended as a critical and Commercial
failure grossing just 80 million dollars
against a budget of 60 million dollars
even its audience scores sits at a
rather low 49 however those willing to
give this science fantasy film a chance
might be pleasantly surprised the world
of the film is fully realized and
believable its grittiness almost
tangible Christian Bales Quinn and
Matthew McConaughey's Dentin are both
compelling characters with conflicting
ideologies that build a convincing
tension throughout its 102 minute run
time and honestly the CGI dragons
actually look pretty amazing considering
how aged the movie is even more amazing
is the fact that CGI isn't overused
which is something to be celebrated in
and of itself
ask any fan of Die Hard to rank every
film in the series and Die Hard with a
Vengeance is unlikely to be anywhere
near the bottom in fact the general
consensus puts the third film right at
the top of the pile beaten out only by
the original 1988 movie
of the worst reviewed entries of the
franchise in many ways this third film
is completely different than what came
before it John McLean has seen a
dramatic Fall From Grace kicked off the
police force he's now living a disgraced
life as an alcoholic it's almost like
he's just the washed up shell of who he
might have been if he'd never want
hollyback invested Hans Gruber at the
top of the nakatomi plaza or thwarted
the Renegade soldiers at Dulles
International Airport all in all though
these changes work out in the end the
banter in chemistry between Bruce Willis
and Samuel Jackson is second to none and
results in some perfect comedy moments
God are you aiming for these people oh
maybe they're mine Jeremy Irons is
villainous character Simon is another
highlight as is the bizarre Simon Says
game he plays that has McLean going all
over New York to stop bombs from
exploding in the city we eventually
learned that Simon is Hans gruber's
brother which creates a legitimate
connection to the first film and
subverts the previous Trope that McLean
is just a coincidental hero who
continually happens to be in the right
place at the right time
unlike typical Disney Princess movies
that are fully animated The Princess
Diaries is a coming-of-age comedy that
is entirely live action featuring The
talents of Anne Hathaway and Julie
Andrews it's based on Meg Cabot's novel
of the same name and follows a young
girl living in the U.S who suddenly
discovers that she is the heir to a
European Kingdom
princess shut up tutored in how to act
as a Royal by your grandmother she must
ultimately decide whether she wants to
become a queen or renounce the throne
critics were initially underwhelmed with
the 2001 film feeling it was lacking in
story and trying to be too many things
at once but there's a good selection of
genuinely funny moments and the film is
constantly endearing with standout
performances from both Andrews and
Hathaway the film never comes across as
overly preachy either yeah it's full of
moral lessons but it doesn't shove them
in your face letting them come out
naturally as the action unfolds as a
clean and harmless film it makes great
family viewing and serves as yet another
example of a movie that you can just
turn on and enjoy even if it's already
half over
laughs